hello everyone
welcome to simply learns youtube channel
today we will be learning the java
programming
in this particular java programming
tutorial we will be having a complete
brief overview of all the major
fundamentals
in java programming language if you are
new to our youtube channel
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel as we have daily updates
on multiple technologies
and also hit that bell icon so that you
can never miss an update from
us so this particular java programming
tutorial
is divided into two parts the
fundamentals
and the object oriented programming
concepts so without further ado
let's begin with the fundamentals so the
first one
in the fundamentals is the data types so
every programming language has a data
type
so what exactly is a data type so
whatever the input you provide
in your program is a data type for
example
if you provide numbers so in that
particular numbers
we have a different variety of numbers
if you are given
just 1 2 3 so on without a decimal
number
then that particular type of input which
is a number will be considered as
integer type if you provide the same
number with a decimal point
then that will be considered as float
and if you have the
range greater than float it will be
considered as double
and so on so this is how we have
multiple data types in every programming
language
so the most frequently used data types
in java programming languages are as
follows
at first we have the byte followed by
that we have short
and long next float then double
boolean and finally care apart from this
we also have few other data types but
these are the most frequently used ones
for all the basic programmings so this
is made for beginners basically so you
can take a quick
screenshot of this particular slide so
that you can have a quick
overview or reference to all the data
types in java programming language
so i hope you have taken a screenshot of
this now let's begin with the next
concept
so in the next concept we have the
keywords and variables
so all the programming languages have
variables
and keywords so variables are used to
store the values
so for example consider that you wanted
to run some automatic operation on two
different values
that is 5 and 10. so in order to do so
you might want to create a variable
which stores them
for example you wanted to store the
value of 10 in a certain variable
a and the 5 in a certain variable
b so if you apply the arithmetic
operation that is
a is equals to a plus b then the value
of a
which was previously 10 will be updated
to 15
so here you can see the value is varying
and also it is storing the result
so this is why the variables are used in
a program
in order to store a value and this
particular term
variable is used because the value can
change
at any instance of time once after a
certain arithmetic or
a logical operation is performed on that
particular variable
so similarly we have keywords unlike
variables keywords have a special
meaning no matter whatever you try
you cannot change the meaning of that
keyword for example consider
main so you cannot use the term main for
normal things
because the part or the term main is
dedicated for a different purpose
so whenever you try to execute your java
program
the control flow will start executing
the program
right when it reads the term main so it
has a special meaning
similarly you have other key words such
as end so that is dedicated for integer
type of
values and float for float type of
values that is a decimal values
and white for byte care for character
type data
string for string so every keyword or
every term with special meaning which is
predefined
and cannot be changed is called as a
keyword now
let's see the most frequently used
keywords in java programming language
so similar to the previous one we have a
table here so in this particular table
we have the most frequently used
keywords in java so you can see we have
boolean
final byte native and we have void
switch so switch is
a conditional statement so we have if
if it is also a conditional statement we
will go through this conditional
statements as we
proceed in our tutorial and you can also
see the protected
so this term which is protected public
so this is basically the
access modifier even this particular
keyword
have special meaning this public this
protected keywords
provide the information to the compiler
or the interpreter
about the accessibility of that
particular data member
or data manipulating method so if it is
protected
from your accessibility or is it
available for you it's provided by
these keywords so we will deal with
access modifiers in the upcoming parts
don't worry about that
and as you can see we have implements
extends so extension this term comes in
inheritance so inheritance is one of the
crucial concepts of object-oriented
programming you can also see abstraction
so this we will be dealing in the next
upcoming part where we will understand
the object-oriented programming concepts
next we have interface return and so on
you can also see some
keywords like through so throw will come
in exception handling so we will also
learn about exception handling in the
upcoming part so
these are the most frequently used
keywords in java
so now we will move ahead into our next
concept so the next concept
is the operators in java so to
understand operators let's go
through a table so on my screen you can
see a table which has some arithmetic
operators
which are most commonly used that is the
plus for addition minus the subtraction
similarly we have star forward slash
double plus double minus
so double plus and double minus say they
are increment and decrement operators
respectively
as you can see we have a plus plus here
which means the post
increment so the first value will be
read after that the value will be
updated
next we have the pre-increment the value
will be
incremented first then the updated value
will be stored so that's that's how the
increment and decrement operators work
so we have the modulus over here
so to understand the operators that we
use in java in a much
better way let's try to execute a sample
program
so on my screen you can see a program
which is based on operators
so we are currently on the eclipse ide
don't worry about the ides and java etc
etc
so i will drop a link in the description
box below which will explain you
in a very detailed way about how to
install
java into your local system and how to
install eclipse ide in your local system
and also how to create your first
project
how to create your package how to create
a new
class how to write your program and how
to run that how to see the output
and a complete overview of the eclipse
ide how that
works so everything will be linked in
the description box below you don't have
to worry about that
so right now to save time i have created
the
text document which has all the programs
that we will be executing today
so i will also drop a link for that
particular file so that you can have
complete access to that file so that you
can run the programs in your
personal pcs or laptops and also
understand the programs in a much better
way so now let's begin with the program
so this particular program is basically
designed for automatic operations
so you can see we have the operators
that is the addition
subtraction multiplication division
modulus and exit
so basically we will be taking input
from mu
so the input will be taken by the user
that is we're using scanner class here
so scanner class takes the input from
user
and that particular input will be
compared
here so we're using the switch case here
so if you provide the option as one then
edition operation will be run similarly
second force abstraction third for
multiplication
fourth for division fifth for modulus
and sixth to exit
so this is how the loop or the program
works for automatic operations
now let's quickly run this program and
see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed
and we have the console asking for the
first input
let's provide some random number now
let's provide the second number
so there you go we have our options over
here now
let's choose division operation for that
we need to provide the number four
so there you go we have the result over
here which is four
now the loop has started once again now
it's in the starting stage again it's
asking for numbers
now let's provide a 25 and
five now let's choose some operation
that is
edition so for that you need to provide
one so we have the result again that is
30. now let's again choose some number
10 5. so basically that's how the
program works
so we have the brief idea how the
program is running now
so now let's quickly continue with our
next topic now
to terminate this loop you can provide
the option number six
so we have terminated it so i hope you
understood how the program flow is
running
so if you did not understand don't worry
i have linked the
document in the description box below
you can take the access of that
particular document and you can
check the program and run in your local
system and also
you can make some modifications to it as
you can see we don't have a default case
over here
i've just placed the case 126 and
i'm seeing the default because you can
see that the options are
from one to six what if the user
provides the
number as seven right so the program
might crash over here so for that
purpose you can write in
another case that would be the default
case so the default case
will check if the number is anything
above or out of the range of
one to six then it should be providing
you with an output saying
a wrong input has been given or check
your input or something similar
so that's how you can make some
modifications to it you're free to
modify the code as well don't worry
about that
so now let's quickly begin with our next
concept so in the next concept we have
the conditional statements
so what are the conditional statements
or the control statements
so basically these are some yeah these
are conditions
so what happens is just imagine that
you wanted to do something or if you
wanted to
drive a vehicle or if you wanted to
drive a bike so
the condition you will apply on your
mind
is if i know driving then i will do it
if not i'll not do it so that's what you
do right so basically you apply a
condition on your mind and you do it if
it is capable of doing or if you are
capable of doing it
so in the same way the conditional
statements play a major role
in computer logic so before writing a
code or before you start your program
you provide the condition
perform this particular operation if the
provided condition is satisfied
so similarly you have these three
conditional statements in java which are
if else and nested if
so we use these conditional statements
in java to
implement our logic so we will
understand the conditional statements
particularly if if else and nested if in
a much more detailed way by
practically running some programs based
on these three types of
conditional statements so now you can
see that we are back on the eclipse
right now
so this particular code segment is based
on the if condition
i hope the program is visible let's try
to increase the font size
so i think it's better now so basically
we have
an input so we have the integer type of
input that is
num and we have the number as -100
so it is a negative number and after
that we have the
if condition so this is where the
conditional statement is provided
so the condition is if the number is
greater than 0 if the provided number is
greater than 0
then the control should enter the loop
which is this particular segment and
execute the statements present
inside that particular loop so here we
have one
single statement that is a print
statement
that says the number is positive in case
the condition fails imagine that the
condition
fails then what happens is that instead
of entering this particular code segment
this particular code segment the control
will skip
and execute the next statement that is
another printf statement which
we have over here which says the if
condition is terminated
control is outside the condition block
now since we have provided a negative
number the second option should go ahead
now let's try to run this and see the
output so there you go
as expected the program got executed and
we have only
one statement that is if condition is
terminated control is outside the block
now let's write
otherwise let's just eliminate the
negative number
and now check it again there you go now
you can see
the program got executed and now we have
two
print statements you can see that the
condition
here was true so the control entered
into the
statement or the code block and this
particular statement got
executed successfully once the
statements are executed and there is
nothing else to do
then the control will automatically exit
this particular statement
and it will enter into the next
statement which is another printf
statement
and we have the same output over there
so this is how the
single if statement works so you can
also modify this with an
else so that's the next program that we
are going to see
we are going to execute some similar
kind of example
for our next kind of conditional
statement that
is if else so here only we had
one if condition so in case if this
particular condition
fails then we will be having another
condition over here
which will be the else block so as you
can see we have
another program so this particular
program is based on
if else condition so here you can see
that we have our
first if condition which states number
should be greater than or equals to zero
if this particular
condition is true then this statement
should be executed which says the number
is positive
else else if this condition fails
then what you must do the control should
avoid entering this particular segment
and it should directly hit the next
segment
where we have the else block which has
another statement
which says the number is negative so
this is how the program works
so here we will be doing a little
modification over there
instead of taking an input which is
previously defined as it was in the
previous example where we had
given minus 100 previously we are going
to do it a little differently
this time we'll be taking or reading the
input directly from the user so for that
we are going to use this scanner class
so this is the particular library that
we will be using so we have imported
java.util.scanner so this particular
code segment will
ask you for the input and you will press
some random number and it will read it
as its input
now let's try to quickly run this
program and see the output
there you go the program was
successfully executed and now it is
asking for an input from the user
now let's try to provide a negative
number
so there you go the program got
successfully executed
and you can see that since we had given
a negative number
the control did not enter this
particular code segment
at all it directly avoided to enter this
code segment
and entered into the else block and
executed the statements present
in that particular else block which was
a simple print statement
that had the statement which read as the
number is negative
now let's try to execute the same
program again and see
what would be the output so there you go
now it's asking for the input again now
this time
let's provide a positive number so there
you go since
we provided the number as a positive
number
this condition was true and this
particular statement got executed
since one of the statements executed
there was no need
for the else block to be executed again
so you can see
this particular code segment runs in
this way so once the condition is
checked
so if the condition is true then the
true statement will be executed
in case if the conditions result is
false
then the false statements will be
executed so you will be provided with
two options
so one option for true validity and
another option for false validity
so this is how the if else block works
i hope you understood this now with this
let's continue with the next type of
conditional statement that is the lzf
ladder so on my screen you can see there
is a change of program we have
stepped into the next type of
conditional statement that is the elsef
ladder
so basically everything will be seen we
will be provided with only one condition
so we will be checking the validity of
that particular condition
so if the provided condition is true
then the first one will be executed
if it is not then the second one will be
executed
if the condition fails for the first two
the third one will be executed
if the first three failed then the
fourth and if all the four
fails then we will have one last else
which will print the last segment or
statement
so this is how the lc flatter works so
basically it's completely similar to if
else
but the only difference is instead of
one else block we have multiple else
blocks that's the only difference
now let's quickly execute this program
and say the output so
basically we are going to take an input
from the user
so we will be entering one for noodles
two for milkshake three for fruits
four for coffee so something like that
and if we provide anything
else then one two three four then we
will be having an
else statement which says it's an
invalid input so the
flow of this particular elsif statement
is similar to
the switch statement having said that we
will also discuss
something about switch statement as well
basically we'll try to execute a program
based on
switch statement and we will also
understand the control flow of that
don't worry about it
now let's quickly execute this
particular program first so
there you go the program got
successfully executed now it's asking
for an
input let's select noodles
that's how it works we have the output
nodals so
the choice is equal to is equals to one
so the first one was
true so it executed the first code
segment and
everything else got suspended because uh
this was not necessary
to be executed because the condition was
true over here and
according to that only this particular
statement was supposed to be executed so
that's how it
works now let's switch into the next
conditional statement
which is the switch so you can see that
we have a program on my screen which is
based on switch case
so you can see that there is some
similarity between this particular
program and the first program we dealt
with that is based on operators
so we also have the default code segment
over here so this was what i was talking
about
you can add a default code segment in
that particular program which is the
operators program and do some
modifications so this is what the
suggestion i gave over there
now basically what happens in this
particular code segment
is so we have monday as the day one of a
week tuesday at the day two of the week
and so on so uh to select one particular
day of a week you need to provide an
input
so it's based on one two three four and
so on to seven
and if you provide anything else than 1
2 7
you will be provided with an message
which says invalid input
so now let's try to run this program and
see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed
now let's select the weekend day so
which would be something between six and
seven so six is saturday and seven is
sunday
let's go with seven so there you go
sunday now let's try to execute this
program
once again and give a wrong input and
see if it works or not
let's provide 8 there you go the program
identified it as a wrong input so it
gave us a message
invalid input so that's the use of
default
code segment in switch case so you can
implement this in that
operator's program and check out how it
works can be considered as a homework
though
not a problem now this is how the switch
case works so with this
let's move ahead into the next concept
in our java tutorial for today
so the next segment is about the
loops so what are loops so conditional
statements
are some statements which get executed
based on a condition if the condition is
true if not
then that particular condition will not
be executed loops are a little different
from conditional statements
how so basically you will be provided
with one single statement
and you wanted to execute that one
single statement
for a particular number of times so in
that condition
instead of writing the same code segment
for several number of times
you can just use a loop for example
consider that you wanted to print
numbers from 1 to 10. so the
brute force method or the simple or the
first method
that fires to your mind is write that
print statement for 10 times
that is print 1 print 2 print 3 and so
on to print 10
but what if you had to print hundred
numbers okay
doable you can write the same print
statement for 100 times
but what if you had to print thousand
numbers
imagine one billion can you do one
billion print statements
no right so in that scenario you can use
loops
so you can just write one condition
repeat
this particular print statement for 1
billion times
then the interpreter or the compiler
will take care of that so
that's the reason why we use loops in
java
so basically we have three loops in
every programming language that is the
for loop while loop and do while loop so
a loop statement in java
execute a set of statements until a
specific condition is satisfied
so here the one billion example so here
you will start from the zeroth
count so that will be the counter
variable which counts the number of
repetitions
and followed by the counter variable you
will be having the condition
so you will be having the count of
variable i i
is less than or equal to the number 1
billion
so until that you have to print this
particular statement
and followed by that you will be having
the increment or decrement operator in
this case you need to use the increment
operator
for the first time once the print is
done
you will increment the value to 2 and
the loop will be iterated once again
so this will continue the loop will
iterate itself until 1 2
3 4 so on and until it reaches 1
billionth
number so that's when the condition
fails i
is greater than or equal to 1 billion
so that's when the condition fails the
condition was to be
i should be less than or equal to 1
billionth
so when the number increments above 1
billion
then the condition fails so the
condition was the number should be less
than or equal to billion
but the number has exceeded the billion
so that's when the loop terminates and
executes the next statement after the
loop
so i think this was a little clear about
the loop
workflow now to understand the loops in
a much more better way
let's execute an example for each one of
these types of loops
so we have follow while open do while
loop let's execute the program for all
of these three
so you can see that we have a program on
my screen so this particular program is
based on for loop
so you can see that the code part
highlighted on my editor is the follow
so you can see int i is equals to 1. so
this is the counter variable
so i is the counter variable which
stores a number
from where the count should begin so
sometimes you can choose
zero sometimes one or the number of your
choice so here i've chosen the number
one
so after the initialization part we have
the condition part
so remember the one billionth example we
discussed before
so here we have i should be less than or
equal to 10.
so this particular loop segment will run
until the condition that is i value
should be less than or equal to 10 is
satisfied once it turns false the
control will
exit the for loop so that's how it's
designed to work with
now followed by the condition we have
the pre-increment operator
once the condition is checked the
control will
jump to the next statement that is the
pre-increment operator
and it increments the value of 1 to 2.
so this is how the loop works now let's
try to execute this program and see the
output
there you go the program got
successfully executed and the output has
been printed
so basically what was the statement to
be executed it was a printf statement
looped plus here the plus symbol works
as a concatenation operator
here too now in between the printf
statements we have the
value of i so in the first place i was
equals to 1
once the pre-increment was taken place
the value of i will be increased to 2
so there you go you can see the number 2
over there now
in the second iteration we print the
value looped
two times similarly in the third
iteration
looped three times so that's how it
works until
the last iteration that is looped 10
times
so once the condition is checked here
the control will enter into the next
part where the pre-increment takes place
so the pre-increment increments the
value of
10 to 11. now the control will come back
to the initialization part
here we have the new value for i that is
11
now 11 will be checked against the
condition
is 11 less than or
equal to 10 no right so the condition
here
fails now the loop is terminated
the control will exit the loop so this
is how the for loop works
now let us also consider another example
for follow
for a better understanding so in this
particular program we are going to
print the sum of n numbers
so in that particular n numbers we will
be having
even numbers and odd numbers for example
consider that
you have provided the number as 5. so
the numbers in between 0 to 5 or 1 to 5
are 1 2 3 4 and 5. so the 4 is even
number
and apart from 4 everything else are odd
numbers
so odd numbers are the numbers which are
divisible by 1 or
itself so now the sum of odd numbers
is 1 plus 2 is 3 3 plus 3 is 6 6 plus
5 is 11 so that's how you print the sum
of
odd numbers and the sum of even numbers
that is only 4. so that's how the loop
works here you have the condition if
else condition
and out of that if else condition you
have the for loop so this particular
loop should be running
until a given number that will be given
by you so that's how the
program works now let's quickly execute
this program and see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and now it's
asking for an input
let's check out five itself now you can
see we have another program on my screen
which is basically based on the same for
loop
so here we have the for loop we will be
providing an input which is
num and inside that we have another
condition
that is the if else loop so basically if
loop is dedicated to find out the even
numbers
and l slope is dedicated to find out the
odd numbers
now the whole motto of this particular
program is to find
the sum of even numbers and the sum of
odd numbers
between 0 to the input number which you
provide for example consider if we
provide the number
5 as the input then in between 0 to 5
we have odd numbers and even numbers so
the even numbers are
2 and 4 and the odd numbers are 1 3 and
5.
so basically what happens here is we are
going to add up the numbers
so the sum of even numbers that is 2 and
4s6
and sum of odd numbers that is 5 plus 3
is 8
8 plus 1 is 9. so that's how it should
work now let's quickly try to execute
this program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and now it's
asking for an input
now let's enter 5 itself and see the
output
so there you go the sum of even numbers
up to 5
is 6 and the sum of odd numbers up to 5
is 9.
so this is how the program works now
apart from for loop we
also have another way to declare the
same for loop
so that particular type of for loop is
called as the
enhanced for loop or in some cases it's
also called as
advanced for loop let's see how the for
loop is declared in a different way
so instead of using the typical for loop
which has the initialization state then
the condition then the
increment or post increment or decrement
kind of operations
we simply have declared the for and
inside that we have
end arr which is the name of the
variable
of array type and inside that we have
the array
so our array consists of 10 numbers
followed from 1 to 10
and now this particular loop will
execute for 10 times
or until all the values in the array are
printed so now let's try to print this
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and we have all
our
values from 1 to 10 which were the input
or
the saved part of the array now with
this let's continue with the next kind
of loop that happens to be the while
loop so
you can see an example based on while
loop on my screen so basically
everything is same
uh there is no much of a difference
between for loop and while loop but the
only difference is the keyword
instead of for we have a vial over here
so
so
we have the while condition over here
which says i
should be less than or equal to num
divided by 2 and if this condition is
true then the control should enter into
the conditional statement
if num modulus i is equals to equals to
0 flag is equals to true and prick
so basically the whole motto of this
program is to find out if the given
particular number
is a prime number or not now let's
quickly try to
run this program and see the output now
you can see the program got successfully
executed
let us try to provide a prime number and
see if the program could identify it
correctly as a prime number or not
there you go the prime number we
provided was 5 and the program
successfully identified it as a prime
number
so that's how the while loop works now
let's execute another program based on
while loop but this time we will place
the condition at the end of the loop
so yeah you guessed it right this is do
while loop
the only difference between while loop
and do while loop is that
before the condition is checked
in while loop no statement is executed
but it's completely opposite when it
comes to do while loop
first the program or the code segment
will be completely executed
after that the condition will be checked
surprising right
let's check out the practical part yeah
we have our
program on my screen right now so uh
in the previous program we had the
condition somewhere over here that's the
file condition but here we have the do
statement here
so what we are going to do is we are
conveying the compiler or the
interpreter to execute
this particular statement first without
checking the
while condition so this is the only
difference between
while loop and do while loop so we have
run the program successfully and
it got executed and we were supposed to
actually print the values of
i from 1 to 20 and they have printed
over here
that's how it works simple right now
with this let's continue with our next
topic
so basically the next topic is the next
segment
in our tutorial that happens to be the
object oriented programming
in java so before we begin with the
object oriented programming concepts
the first major things that we need to
learn are the classes and objects
so the whole object-oriented programming
concept revolves around these two
basic fundamentals which are the classes
and objects
so what exactly are the classes and
objects let's learn
them through a definition so classes can
be defined as a template
or a blueprint that describes the
behavior or state that the object of its
type
supports and in java the objects have
states and behaviors an object is an
instance of the class
okay it sounds a little complicated let
me break this down through using some
simple concepts
so imagine that you wanted to build a
car let's consider the tesla car
so if you wanted to build some n number
of tesla cars
then before that you need a blueprint of
that particular car
so here the blueprint of the tesla car
can be considered as the class
so using the same blueprint you can
create
any number of cars which are called as
instances in the language or in the
terms of java
so the cars or the instances that you
create using the blueprint that is using
the class
is known as an object so this is how it
works
so basically the blueprint of what you
used to construct is called as
the class so we'll also talk about the
constructors in a while
the object or the thing which got
constructed using the blueprint is
called as the object
so i hope this was a little clear so now
we will learn the constructors in java
so first we will begin with the
definition of a constructor
so constructor is basically a built-in
method that is used to initialize
objects
the constructor is called when the
object of a class is created
so as we discussed before so whenever
you wanted to create a new object
you use the blueprint that is the class
so whenever you wanted to initiate
the process of creating an object then
the constructor is called by the
interpreter then it starts the process
of building the objects so this is the
basic technicality how the background
process works using the constructor
so typically there are two types of
constructors in java one is the
parameterized constructor
and the other one is the default
constructor
now next in the docket is the first one
out of the object-oriented programming
concepts
that is the abstraction so we will
understand the definition of abstraction
first
so abstract class is a template of
methods
and variables used in a program abstract
class
cannot be instantiated directly so
we read that the objects are created by
instantiating the class
but here we have the abstract class so
the term abstract basically
explains it all so abstract is like you
are keeping something
from the user so when you create a
program or when you create a software
there are a whole number of complexities
in the program
so imagine yourself being the developer
and some client comes to you
for some kind of software so what is the
client concerned about is the final
product
he is not concerned about your ways of
implementing logic or your coding
process or whatever it is
so basically abstraction is providing
the user
with the information or the details he
requires or
he feels necessary and you try to avoid
the user
from getting into the complex coding
part you are avoiding him from reaching
to the complex coding part so basically
that's what the abstract last means
providing the end user with the
necessary information by hiding the
complex details of coding
now to understand abstract classes in a
much better way let's go through a
sample program
so on my screen you can see an example
for abstract class
so how can you identify a class as
abstract simple
you can see the keyword abstract over
here so basically what we're trying to
do here is
we're going to create a abstract class
on the name of person
and this particular person will be
having the name and gender
so once the abstract class is created we
are going to instantiate this particular
blueprint
or the main class to create an object
which has an employee
so basically our object here will be mr
pawan
so mr pawan jane who is going to be the
object out of the
class person right so this is the
blueprint the person is the blueprint
and we are using this particular person
blueprint to create this
employee object which is mr parvin jain
who happens to be an employee for
certain company
now we will run this code and see the
output don't worry
you will be having the access to the
code and you can apply your
own modifications and you can execute
this program in your own system and have
a deep understanding of the code so now
let's
run this code so there you go we have
successfully instantiated
the person class which is the main
abstract class and we have created our
object
that happens to be mr pawan jain and his
gender is
male so this is how basically the
classes and object work and this is how
the abstract classes work we are hiding
the implementation here we are just
providing the
necessary information what the user
needs the unnecessary information is if
the object has successfully created or
not or if the
employee mr powenjian has logged into
the company or not so that's what
exactly is the technicality of abstract
classes
now with this let's continue with the
next concept in the
object-oriented programming in java so
the next concept in the object-oriented
programming
in java will be about the different ways
to achieve
abstraction so we have already dealt
with one method of
obtaining abstraction which is by using
the abstract classes
and we also have another way of
implementing abstraction
without using abstract class so that
particular way is by using
interface and this particular interface
is also used in another way it will also
come handy when you wanted to implement
inheritance by multiple classes so we
will discuss about that
multiple inheritance trouble and diamond
problem and types of inheritances
in a bit more detail in the upcoming
concepts for now let's understand what
exactly is an interface and let's also
check out
a basic example for interface
so now the definition of interface an
interface is actually a container
that stores the signatures of methods to
be implemented in the code segment
so basically if you look into the
previous example
in the employee class we have declared
the complete method that means we have
completely written
the implementation details the logics
used in the method
but when it comes to interface we just
write
the method signature so complete method
is different from complete method
signature so method signature will be
the name of the method but inside that
particular method
no particular code segment will be
written but the implementation part will
be
written separately apart or outside the
interface
now for a better understanding yeah i
know this is a little bit confusing
now we will understand this through an
example i think that will be a bit clear
to you
let's switch to the eclipse mode again
so now we are in the eclipse mode again
so let me give you a brief overview of
how to create an interface so basically
you
navigate to the package so here we have
the simply learn java package
right click on it and you can see a
dialog box and inside that you can see
new option and you can see another
dialog box or
drop down menu and there you can see an
option called interface
so when you click this you will have a
new dialog box
then you can just provide some name to
your interface now
let me just provide simply learn
and just finish and there you go you
have the
interface created now right now we don't
need this interface specifically
we have already designed an interface
for us so the interface
for this particular program is
area dot java so you can see that inside
area.java
we have method signatures remember the
method signatures that we spoke about in
the definition so this is what i meant
about the method signature so we have
the
public void square so this particular
interface is designed to calculate the
area of different shapes
so first we have the square next we have
the circle
the rectangle and the triangle but
wait a minute we don't have the formula
for square we have the formula side into
side but
where is the implementation of this
particular area calculation
and similarly we have circle pi r square
so where is the implementation and
similarly for rectangle
we don't have the implementation and
triangle we don't have the
implementation
we just have the method signature so
where exactly is the method
implementation yes so here we are
avoiding the user from the complex
implementation of the code
so the complex implementation of this
particular code is inside
shape area class so you can see
for the first one which is the circle we
have the code implementation over here
so we will take the input of the radius
from user
so we have the scanner class over here
which will read the input and similarly
we have
the implementation for square so we will
take the input again which is kb2
keyboard 2
and again we have the implementation for
rectangle kb3 which is the keyboard 3
then at last we have the triangle we
have kb4 which takes the input for
the height of the triangle and base of
the triangle and then we have the
calculation over here
which says height into base into
0.5 basically the formula is half into
basin to height so
half as 1 by 2 so the value of 1 by 2
will be 0.5
so that's how it goes on and here we
will call the methods
so that's how the interface works now
let's quickly run the program and see
the output
wait a minute there is some error
so uh on this note i would like to give
you a
quote maybe yeah when it doesn't work
for the first time
call it version one so don't worry when
you face errors
okay we have specific groups for java
programming
in telegram you can post your errors or
if you
have any issues in your projects or any
type of problems related to programming
you can directly copy paste your error
into that group and we will
answer your questions because we are a
group of professional java programmers
and we are also a group of ed tech
organizations
so we have a good knowledge of java and
we really believe that we can help you
out
so for now let's try to refresh the
package
and let's check one last time if we have
any kind of
issues or warnings or errors on the
program
so so far i can't see anything
so let's try to give it a one last try
now we have gone through the one final
checklist through the entire code and we
found
no errors or no warnings so even in the
interface
now let's try to run it again so
there you go it's running successfully
so once you get some kind of errors of
warnings don't worry
just try to refresh the code and try to
fetch some warnings or any issues
regarding code and try to fix them
and yeah that should help now coming
back to our
console you can see that the console is
asking for an input for radius now let's
provide the input
15 and there you go we have our output
over here which says 7.6
units as the area of the circle
now in the next section the console is
asking for us for an input
for the square length of the square
so let's provide 10. so the formula is
as into s so it must give us 100.
now the console has continued into the
rectangle now let's provide the
length part of the rectangle and now the
breadth
so the area is 252 and now it's asking
for the
base of the rectangle
then now the height of the rectangle
and now the area is 625 so
this is how the interface works so
basically the implementation has been
hidden from the end user and
we just have the method signatures over
here so that's how it works
now let's continue with the next topic
in our java programming
so the next topic is the encapsulation
so in the object programming concepts in
java the process of encapsulation is
bundling the data and methods that
operate on
the data a little bit confusing i
understand
but let me clarify this so basically
in object oriented programming you will
be having
objects classes and inside the classes
you will be having data members
so data members are nothing but the
variables which are storing your values
so for example int a is equals to 10
into b
is equals to 20 so a and b are your data
members and data manipulating methods
are simply called as methods
for example if you wanted to perform an
addition operation on a
and b so you will be writing some
method call and inside the method call
you'll be declaring some parameters
which are int a into b
so that particular method which will
perform the addition operation inside
the sum method you will be having a plus
b
so that's exactly what i mean the data
manipulation methods
so the data members a and b and the data
manipulating method which is
sum a plus b so these two
are encapsulated together or kept
together by using the process of
encapsulation
so the term is encapsulating the data
members and methods
so still it might be a little confusing
but let me clarify you about that
in a bit more detail by the practical
session
now let's switch back to eclipse again
where we will understand encapsulation
in java
in a bit more detail and in a little
more depth
so on my screen you can see two
different programs so the first one
is the encapsulate class and the second
one is the run class
so basically what we are doing in the
run class so in the run class
just imagine that we have some person
his
h and the id number let's consider that
harry is
25 years old and he works for a company
or
maybe he is into some college so we have
some
id number generated for harry so what we
are going to do is we are just going to
create a profile of harry
so we will be setting the name setting
the h and setting the id
so this is simple now let's get back
into the encapsulation class
so here you can see that we have some
private variables name
id and and h so what we're going to do
here is
we are going to get the age of
harry and we are going to get the name
of harry we are going to get
the id of harry so basically these are
the get and set methods
so after getting those name age and id
values
we are going to set the age name and
values of harry
so what we're doing here is we are
encapsulating
the methods and data members together
in one single class now i hope this
overview gave you a little bit idea of
how encapsulation basically works
now let's quickly run this program and
see the output
yeah again it through some kind of error
don't worry
let's try to refresh the package once
again
now let's try to run the package as a
java
application i hope this should help yeah
don't worry sometimes
these kind of minor issues are thrown
so you just have to refresh your package
or do
an error check or warning check on your
code and that should really help
no worries on that so we have got the
program executed and we have also got
our output which says
name is harry ages 25 and the id is 800
and
not 800 it's 8 lakh 25
let's uh let me just increase the font
size
so it's 8 like 29 468
yeah or 8 2 9 4 6 8.
cool now let's continue with the next
concept in our
java programming
now the next concept happens to be a
really important one which is the
inheritance
so what is inheritance inheritance is an
act
through which a new class gets created
by acquiring the variables and methods
defined in the parent class
so a lot of parent and child
relationship over here
so what exactly happens is uh just
imagine that
you wanted to create a new phone
so what's the basic functionality of a
mobile phone
so you send text messages and
you try to call someone right so this
happens to be some
second generation phones such as the
double one double zero nokia series
so these are an older generation of
phones now you wanted to create a new
brand new the latest generation phone
which are the smartphones
so in a smartphone you will be having
some extra functionalities
such as taking pictures or
if you wanted to record a video or if
you wanted to use social
media internet browsing so these kind of
extra features
so these extra features were not
available in double one double zero
but there is one similarity between w1
double zero and your latest
smartphone that is creating an sms and
sending it
and making a call so making a call and
writing an sms
itself is a complex coding pattern
so when you try to create your
smartphone
will you try to write the entire code
section once again
or will you try to copy paste that code
into your new phone
so copy pasting will be efficient right
so the time saving
so you can consider the same kind of
technicality in inheritance so when you
already have a data member declared and
when you already have a data
manipulating method
defined you can inherit or you can
borrow that particular method
from a different class to your new class
so the class which is going to borrow
the method
from another class is called as a child
class
and the method which provides or which
donates
the data members and the data
manipulating methods to a different
class is called as the parent class
yeah so this should have given you an
overview so
now let's understand in a bit more
detail and in-depth kind of approach
to inheritance in practical sessions but
before that
we have some different varieties of
inheritance in java
now let's dive into the types of
varieties in
inheritance in java
so there are basically four varieties
which are the single inheritance
multi-level inheritance
hierarchical inheritance and hybrid
inheritance
so consider taking a screenshot of this
so that you can have a quick overview
so the first level a classes which are
colored in blue color
are the parent classes and the next
level classes are the child classes so
in the first type of inheritance we can
find
a is providing the data members or data
manipulation
methods to the class b so here class b
is a child class and a is the parent
class similarly in multi-level
inheritance
so this is similar to the single level
inheritance but the difference is
c is inheriting some properties from b
as well as the properties from a
so this happens to be multi-leveled kind
of inheritance
and on the third kind we can see there
are multiple classes
inheriting the properties from one
single parent
so you can see that a is providing the
data members and data manipulating
methods
to all the three child classes which are
b c and d
and finally we have the hybrid
inheritance so the name
itself is self-explanatory so the term
hybrid
refers to the combination of all the
other three
kind of inheritances so you can see at
the first level
there is hierarchical inheritance so b
and c
are inheriting the same property from a
and in the next level we can see that
there is a single inheritance between
parent class c and child class d
and if you consider the
relationship between parent class a
child c and
child class d then you can see that
there is
multi-level inheritance so this
particular inheritance is a combination
of all the three inheritances
so apart from these four there is
another type of inheritance
so that particular inheritance is called
the
multiple inheritance but in java when
you try to implement
multiple inheritance there is a serious
chance of
ambiguity so for that one reason java
authors decided not to include multiple
inheritance
so if you wanted to implement multiple
inheritance
for that purpose you can make use of
interface
so interface gives you the logical
approach of
multiple inheritance but without the
ambiguity
of diamond problem now let's try to
understand all these types of
inheritances in a much more detail and
elaborate way
through the practical session now let's
get back to the eclipse
screen again now we are back on the
eclipse mode right now
so on my screen you can see a simple
program which says
single so the name of the program is
single or the main class is single
so we have two particular classes so the
student class is the parent class and
the bob class is the child class
so what you're going to do here is
you're going to extend the properties of
student class into the popular that
basically means you are trying to borrow
some
methods or data members from the parent
class into the child class
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output
so there you go the properties of parent
class which was basically a small printf
statement
are being extended by the child class
and both these messages have been
successfully printed in the output
console
now let's try to execute another program
based on
inheritance but this time we will
execute the program based on
multi-level inheritance
so on my screen you can see another
example based on inheritance
but this time we are going to implement
multi-level inheritance
so basically we have the parent loss
that happens to be the by class
and inside the by-class we have two
printf messages
and now followed by the main parent
class we have the first child class that
is the ninja
so ninja is a bike from the brand
kavasiki
and now ninja is going to extend the
first parent class that is the bike
so that it will inherit the properties
of a bike
now followed by that we have another
class
or you can say child class which is
ninja
1000r so inside the ninja segment
we have different varieties so the
variety what we are dealing here is the
ninja 1000
r so this particular ninja 1000r is
going to extend the ninja segment or the
ninja class and it is going to borrow
the properties of a ninja segment bike
and above that ninja bike is going to
extend the properties of a tubular
now this is the flow what i have
designed for this particular program
so that it looks a little simple to
understand now let's try to run this
program and see the output
so there you go we have the program
successfully executed and we have the
output on the console
so make us the ninja ninja model as the
1000r
bike type is a sports type manufacturer
is kavasiki and the maximum speed is 280
kilometers per hour
now let's move into the next type of
inheritance that has the hierarchial
inheritance
so on my screen you can see another
example based on inheritance but this
time you're going to deal with
hierarchical inheritance so as discussed
before in the theory part
hierarchy inheritance has multiple child
classes which are going to inherit the
properties of
one single parent so here
that one single parent happens to be the
employee class
and followed by that we have two
different varieties of
child classes which are pre-employed so
p employer is basically the permanent
employee and
the t employee is basically the
temporary employee
so both the temporary and permanent
employees are going to extend the
properties of
employee so inside the employee we have
one data member which is the leaves
so both for a permanent employee and the
temporary employee the company provides
the same number of leaves that has 25
but
they have different working guys though
just to make sure that
these two classes also have some data
members i have included the total work
hours per day
for both permanent employee and
temporary employee
now let's try to execute this program
and say the output f
these two child classes are capable to
inherit the properties which are the
leaves from
the main class or the parent class
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and the output got
generated on the output console
you can see that the total number of
leads for both permanent employee
and temporary employee are same that is
25
that means both the permanent employee
and temporary employee
have inherited the properties from the
parent class
or one single parent class that is the
employee
so that's how the irrql inheritance
works
now let's move ahead into the last type
of inheritance that is the
hybrid inheritance so you can see that
we have an example on my screen which is
based on
hybrid inheritance so in hybrid
inheritance
different childs are going to inherit
from different variants
in a different manner so to make things
a bit
more comfortable i have designed this
particular program
based on the theoretical part what we
have discussed so when we get back into
the theory part
we can see that in the hybrid
inheritance
two child classes which are b and c are
inheriting
the hierarchical inheritance from the
class a
and the class c and class d are in the
form of a single inheritance and d
is extending from c and here you can see
that
d is also extending c as well as a which
forms as a multi-level inheritance
now we shall try to execute a program on
the same type of inheritance or
the same type of approach
so to understand this program we need to
execute this program so that
the output print statements can explain
us in a better way
now let's quickly try to execute this
program and see the output
so you can see that the program was
successfully executed and we have the
specific messages over here so the first
one has to say that
c has single inheritance with class a
and shares hierarchy with b let's verify
it so c has a single inheritance with a
and shares hierarchy
with b so that's true
and followed by that a is the parent of
all the classes
including b c and d yeah that's true
and we has a single inheritance with a
and shares hierarchy with c
and also that is true b has single
inheritance with a
and shares hierarchy with c
and lastly d has single inheritance with
c
and multi-level inheritance with a so
let's check that out
yeah d has single inheritance with c and
a multi-level inheritance with
a so i hope you understood how the
hybrid inheritance works
now with this let's move into the next
concept in object oriented programming
that is the polymorphism in java
so we will begin by understanding the
definition of polymorphism
so basically polymorphism is the ability
of any object in a class to perform task
in multiple methods
so this type of approach is called as
polymorphism in
java so there are two types of
polymorphism
runtime polymorphism and compile time
polymorphism
so to understand things in a much better
way we shall move through a practical
session
let's consider a method okay let's
consider some addition method
so in your program you wanted to perform
addition on two different operators
and there might be a situation that you
wanted to perform
the same edition operation on three
different operators
but by the suspense here is you wanted
to specify
the name of the method with a d d
add and for both the methods you'll be
having the same
name right so this might create an
ambiguity
but you can avoid this by specifying the
number of parameters
when you pass the method or when you
create a method call with
two parameters then the first method
will be called
when you pass three parameters then the
second method will be called
which has three operators so basically
the evaluation of this particular
command will take place during the
runtime
and sometimes similar kind of operations
takes place during the compile time
so this is what polymorphism is so to
understand what polymorphism
exactly is and what is a runtime
polymorphism and what is a compile-time
polymorphism
we shall quickly dive into the practical
mode so that we can have
an in-depth understanding now let's
first get back to eclipse and try to
execute some programs based on
polymorphism
runtime polymorphism and compile time
polymorphism
so on my screen you can see the program
based on polymorphism
so basically we have four different
classes the first one will be the animal
sounds class next we have the cow class
which will be extending the same
animal sounds pairing class next we have
cat and followed by that we have the dog
so basically what we are going to do
here is we are going to call the sound
method
and the sound method belonging to that
particular class
will be executed based on the parameter
or based on the
object that got created now let's try to
execute this program and see the output
so there you go the program was
successfully executed and the sound
method is successfully implemented based
on the
method call so you can see that we have
called the cow
sound method twice and it got mo
over here so that's what the cow makes
as a sound and dog says something
similar like that
so basically the method calls are
resolved during the
run time based on the object created and
the method called
so basically in polymorphism we also
have method overriding and method
overloading
we will understand the concepts through
an example
so as discussed before we have the same
addition operation
example over here so here we have
different types of methods they might
look the same because the name of the
method is add basically
but if you look at the parameters a
little closely you can see that the
first method has
two parameters and both the parameters
are of integer data type
and similarly when you look at to the
third
add method it also has two
parameters but the data type is double
so when you pass a double kind of
data type then the third method will be
used
if you provide the integer data types
then the first method will be used to
perform the edition operation
but if you provide four parameters
all of double type then the second
method will be used
so this type of method resolution in
runtime is called as
method overloading now let's try to
execute this program and see the output
so there you go the program was
successfully executed and as you can see
in the main program
we have already forwarded the parameters
through the function call
and the data got executed and we have
the output over here
now let's go into method overriding and
understand the concept through a
practical program
so on my screen you can see another
example based on polymorphism but this
particular program deals with
method overriding so you can see the
cargo pilot and the civilian pilot
so basically they both want to fly a
plane so to fly a plane they need to
take off from the runway
so the fly plane method will be resolved
in
run time so whichever the object is
called
or whichever the object calls the method
then that particular method will be
executed for that particular object now
here we are going to comment out the
civilian
pilot and we are going to open the cargo
pilot
so when we run this program the cargo
pilot object
could be able to execute the fly plane
method now let's try to execute this
program and see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and the cargo
pilot was free to take off and he just
gave us
the message which says this is cargo
pilot
ready to take off similarly when we
commit out
the cargo pilot
and try to open the civilian pilot
then things get a little changed so
this time the civilian pilot will be
executed
so here the fly plane method got
overridden by the civilian pilot
so this is how the method overriding
works in real time
now with this let's move ahead into the
next concept in java's programming
tutorial
so the next concept in java's
programming tutorial is the java
collections
so java collections are basically the
data structures used in java
so we have the java collections from the
iterable library class in
the java's library and followed by that
we have the collections
then inside the collection we have three
different varieties which are the list
queue and set so when we dig deep into
list q and sets we have the array list
linked list vector stack and similarly
on the queue we have priority queue
dequeue array queue and when we get into
set we have hash set
linked hash set and sorted set reset and
much more so jarvis collections is a
whole new level
concept so to understand java's
collections in a much
more detailed way along with some
practical programs
i will drop down the link in the
description box below which will
redirect you
to simply learns java collections
tutorial
which has the explanation to all the
java collections or
java data structures in a much more
detailed way along with
the practical examples now to continue
with the next topic
we have the enumeration
so what do you mean by enumeration in
java so enumeration is a class type and
it can have constructors methods and
instance variables
so it is created by using the enum
keyword
now to understand enumeration in a much
better way we shall go through a
practical example
so basically enum can be considered as a
general data structure like array
which is designed to store some elements
i think you can have a better
understanding when you actually look at
the program
so let's switch back to the eclipse mode
so there you go you can see an example
of enum
on my screen right now so enum is
basically a data structure
that stores the elements so here we are
storing the elements honda
hyundai and suzuki which are the brands
of
car makers so what's the difference
between
an array or any other data structure and
enums
so if you provide some elements into a
data structure like array
they can be varied through some data
manipulating operations
so when you declare the same elements
using an enum it's
impossible to change the elements in an
enum
now we're going to access the name of
some brands through
this particular statement here now let's
try to execute this program and see the
output
so there you go the program was
successfully executed and one of the
elements from the enum collection has
been printed on the console
now with this let's continue with the
next concept in the java's programming
tutorial
that has the exception handling
so what is an exception what is an error
so exception is basically an unexpected
scenario that pops up during the runtime
and disrupts
the normal execution flow of a program
now what is an error
so an error is an unexpected event that
arises due to logical or syntactical
mistakes and is capable to bring down
the complete program
so an exception is something which is
not
powerful enough to completely crash your
code but it is capable to stop
or disrupt its normal flow just for
example consider that you wanted to
apply some division operation so you
will be providing some
positive integers or negative integers
or any kind of float or double values
during the operation
but consider that you have one normal
number which is an integer number
and the other one is zero
is it possible to divide any number
through 0
no right so this kind of input will
disrupt the normal flow or sometimes
even crash the program so this kind of
problems are called as exceptions
and similarly on the other hand when we
get into errors
errors is a completely new scenario so
error will be arised when you provide
some
wrong logic in your code for example you
wanted to perform division operation
so instead of forward slash you give
some other symbol like
pipe symbol or anything so the computer
might not understand what's the meaning
of that particular symbol
so this is where some logical or
syntactical mistake arises and that ends
up as an error
so to understand errors and exceptions
in a much more better way
i will drop down the link in the
description box below which will
redirect you to simply learns exception
handling tutorial
with some detailed explanation of
exceptions and errors
and how to handle them in real time and
also they have some very
nice examples for exceptions and how to
resolve them in real time
now followed by this we will advance
into our next topic
which will be about file operations
so file handling can be defined as a
procedure to manipulate data
via file system so it includes to create
get read and write operations so
basically what will you be doing is you
will be creating a file
get some information if it has or if you
wanted to write some information into it
if you want then you can do it and after
writing
you can even read the information which
is present in that file
now let's try to create a new file in my
file system
and try to write some data into it and
then try to read it
now let's switch back to eclipse again
so now you can see that on my screen we
have another example based on file
operation
techniques so this time we are going to
perform the right operation so what we
are basically
going to do is we are going to write the
text message status
files in java might be tricky but it is
fun enough
now we are going to write the same data
in simply learn
doc dot txt so for that
let's quickly run the program and see
the output
now let's get back to my file system and
see if the data is written in the
document
now let's open the simply learn doc text
document
so as you can see the files in java
might be tricky but
it's fun enough so this is the exactly
same message what we wanted to write
so files in java might be tricky but
it's fun enough
now the last type of file manipulating
operations will be the read operations
now we will try to read the text which
is present in simplylearn.txt
so now on my screen you can see an
operation for reading the
text data present in simplylearn.txt
now let's quickly run this program and
see if it can read
the data present in that particular text
document or not
so there you go the program was
successfully executed and
the command read the data which is
present in simplylearn.txt
so the text data what we wrote in that
particular file was
files in java might be tricky but it is
fun enough
so with this we have come to an end of
this particular java programming
tutorial
i hope you enjoyed this if you have any
queries regarding this tutorial or if
you
are in need of the text document which
has all the quotes and programs that we
executed in this particular tutorial
then please feel free to write us down
in the comment section below and we will
respond to you
at the earliest this is ravi signing off
until next time thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here